hey 42 here gentlemen I have a question
for you how many wives do you think you
could handle surely one is enough
well according to many know polygamy is
legal and commonly practiced in many
countries throughout Africa the Middle
East and Southeast Asia but for one man
becoming betrothed to even two or three
different women isn't sufficient a man
known simply as Ziona
has a grand total of 39 wives and he's
the head of the world's largest family
astonishingly he also has 94 children
and 33 grandchildren this enormous
family lives in Baton village in
northeast India this quirky village is
built up a hillside hundreds of miles
from anywhere and at its heart sits a
bright purple castle called Chauhan thar
run which means the house of the new
generation this purple monstrosity is
home to all 193 members of the Ziona
family now aged 72 si owner married his
first wife at the humble age of 15 in
1959 since then he has added a new woman
to his Bridal harem every one and a half
years on average and in one year he
married 10 women so the wolf thirty nine
wives sleep in one gigantic bed with
their man as cozy as that sounds it's
actually a rather cold arrangement his
wives are resigned to sleeping in large
communal dorms the youngest women sleep
closest to Z owners bedroom the older
women sleep in a dorm further away as
far as Iona's bed well he only has room
for one woman at a time so how does he
decide who gets to share his almighty
presence each night the woman are on a
rotation and reportedly the female who
is chosen for duty that night will find
a pillow missing from her own bed the
romance is strong with this one as you
can imagine mealtimes are a heavily
regimented affair all thirty-nine wives
must muck in each night to provide a
feast of truly
and proportions every night the wives
must pluck and prepare 30 chickens peel
60 kilograms of potatoes and cook over
100 kilograms of rice schooling is
somewhat of an issue too because the
local village school is not large enough
to accommodate the vast army of children
belonging to Ziona the solution zeona
built his own school exclusively for his
94th children and ever resourceful the
eldest children in the family are the
teachers but the madness doesn't end at
education as I own his sons and
daughters also form the local football
league making up several different teams
and they all compete against each other
regularly as Iona's wives take turns in
waiting hand and foot on their husband
at least eight women will serve Him each
and every day strangely all the women
get along they all have love and a
mutual respect of each other not only is
this a large large family but also a
fully functioning sweatshop to put it
crudely as Iona is a wealthy man because
his family manufactures and sells
furniture hundreds of pieces of it each
year they're purple mansion consists of
several carpentry workshops and all of
the family members who are old enough
work for the family business but here's
the thing in India polygamy is illegal
however it needs remote tribal lands of
India it is permitted for local
religions to set their own laws in
regards to certain things including
polygamy conveniently zeona happens to
have his own religious I know what are
the chances and amazingly his religion
happens to make polygamy legal for all
who follow it as Iona is the head of the
religion which is actually a Christian
sect known as chana Paul the entire
family must pray daily and thy owner
himself is granted almost godlike status
within the village women within the
community feel as though it's an honor
to be Wed to the mountain which explains
why he has
so many wives so let's just be realistic
here as I own out has basically created
a cult with a very loyal following with
the goal of perpetuating his multi wife
fantasies there's got to be easier ways
to be a player I mean this guy's
obviously never heard of tinder thanks
for watching
kowloon walled city was home to over
33,000 people all crammed into a measly
six acres but there's a mud equally as
despicable as Adolphe Hitler yet very
few people even know of his existence